après deux mois à être resté 24 heures
sur 24 l'un sur l'autre sans pause pour
aller au boulot voir ses amis ou prendre
l'air tout seuls certains couples n'ont
qu'une envie après le 11 mai prochain
prendre un peu le large une tendance
qu'un nouveau sondage de l'ifop révèle
alors que certains ont juste besoin de
souffler un peu et de se retrouver seuls
selon cette étude 4 % des couples
pourraient aller jusqu'à la rupture
un pourcentage élevé surtout du côté des
jeunes couples qui ont découvert lors de
ce confinement des détails chez leurs
partenaires qu'il n'avait pas noté
jusque là pour d'autres si la rupture
n'est pas envisagé ce moment de partage
intense était un peu trop long 12% des
sondés déclarent même que si c'était à
refaire il ne passerait pas le
confinement avec leur moitié une
tendance particulièrement prononcé chez
les femmes
du côté des couples qui n'avait pas fait
le choix de passer le confinement
ensemble le temps a pu paraître long 25
% d'entre eux ont même triché en
prétextant de faux déplacement pour
aller rejoindre discrètement leurs
moitiés dernières grandes tendances des
couples pendant ce confinement nombreux
sont ceux qui ont adopté l'amour à
distance sextoys sextos webcams la
tendance explose finalement peut-être
que certains couples ont même trouvé là
un nouveau moyen de pimenter leur
intimité
ouais alors valérie venez on va parler
de ça mais il ya plein de gens qui
disent on veut la photo vous avez envoyé
avaler le ménage 20 millimes
est ce que vous voulez la poster sur
twitter sur votre compte twitter pendant
la journée dans la peau sous la peau bon
à la pause voilà vous la porterez qu'est
ce qui se passe c'est quoi de molesme je
fais l'émission avec mon téléphone et
que la photo est dans mon téléphone ne
sera pas dans la posture pour que je la
trouve très bien vous tout va bien avec
patoche parce que vous avez vu il ya
placé pas rationnellement effectivement
c'était où ça passe ou ça casse c'est là
quand on est l'un sur l'autre pendant 50
jours
attachez vous êtes un pub sympa de voir
la plus grande distance qu'on peut avoir
c'est entre le salon et la salle de
bains pas vraiment d'accord donc ça
limite quand même le truc
et bien figurez-vous que moi ça passe
mais tranquille voilà c'est tout a très
très bien donc ça renforce les liens
ça aurait pu les cas c'est ça les a
renforcés mais merveilleux comédien le
pathos un bon comédien il est très fort
rémo toi ça va moins bien armés ça oui
chez moi ça moi tout va bien sauf une
grande relation comme à valérie les
relations de début de trois ans ça passe
mais c'est des relations cinq six sept
ans que tu avais pas tout vu et que tu
le découvres et c'est là que ça casse
c'est sur les relations qui sont plus
longues que l'allégeance aimé ce qu'est
ce que alors relation plus long un
spécialiste ici cheval
il a les cheveux longs les relations
longue voilà c'est rené malleville voix
de maleville mon run et combien de temps
avec ta femme
ben tu vois je sais que je vais te mets
beaucoup les gens et améliorer chez vous
mais 53 des mariages
c'est toujours moi connais comme fini je
n'ai jamais été aussi près d'elle et
fils était pas d'accord on avait juste
je souhaiterais c'est à dire encore des
mois je retrouve ma part on se retrouve
on parle on discute se disputent plus
parce que n'est pas marseille ap hm on
discutait salopards pour les dames pas
les petits dame falco la madone c'est ce
que la veille au caire une aucun sujet
de 18 ses journées tranquilles
elle est la côte est de voir toute la
journée c'est que du bonheur c'est beau
c'est vrai il fait rêver
est il en train est il en train de
casser le marché du divorce hui au tir
il faut qu il faut aussi que tout le
monde y mette un peu déçu parce qu'il y
avait m tu l'as où tu es allée par allée
il quitta pas lui a fait perdre du poids
innover c'est que tu connais des êtres
connaît des mâts ddd ouvre toi
le mec parce que la soupe au lait face à
l'est quitte sa femme s'il s'en va
parler mais ça se voit crohn et c'est
quelqu'un d'entier et moi je mettrais ma
main à couper qu'il n'a jamais frappé
s'assemble c'est quelqu'un qui est
fidèle qui doit aussi se profiler la
sésamie fidèle à vous maintenant c'est
quelqu'un qui est droit voilà alors
après il peut dire l'om peut dire des
conneries star mais c'est quelqu'un de
chez elle avec toi michel
non mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai
qu'ils avaient marre et adore les je
vais vous donner les dix commandements
je vous donnais les dix commandements à
vous qui nous regardent et pour survivre
en couple les dix commandements à
respecter pour survivre en couple en
numéro 10 discuter et se soutenir en cas
de blues passager est ce que c'est ce
que fait patoche valérie oui papa lui
c'est plutôt un rock donc là il a jamais
d'états d'âme
moi je peux en avoir et c'est vrai que
c'est une oreille attentive et que je
sais que je peux lui dire tout ce que
j'ai sur le coeur et ça c'est super
important dans un coup jean-michel votre
chien c'est pareil ils vous soutiens en
cas de blues chica mais j'ai quand même
noté parce qu' un peu de psychologie
c'est à cammalleri leurs proches va pas
insensible 2 - pas montrer ses
sentiments c'était baroque
c'est un reproche à nice et un roc son
mec savoir proche est native d'accord
dansé un rock
vous avez vu c'est un roc un pathos
c'est un roc ouais t'es sur que c'est
pas un rocher suchard plus tôt alors en
numéro 2 je vous le dis s'accorder des
moments en solo faut savoir rester un
petit peu seul comme jean michel maire
lui s'accorde koné moment en solo basse
et très bien voilà vrai ou pas valérie
vidal est ce que vous le faites super
important vraiment vraiment vraiment
super important tout comme avoir un
petit jardin secret c'est très un accord
en effet quoi votre jardin secret c'est
que votre jardin secret où ben je peux
pas vous le dire non mais des titres
pickwick on regarde pour ça on n'est pas
obligé d'être dans la transparence
absolue
la descente est essentielle et chose
très importante évidemment lady mais des
choses anecdotiques on peut aussi se les
garder pour soi et voilà y avoir des
moments à soi c'est super important
d'accord très bien rené tu as des petits
moments de saut en solo au pain ou et
jordan façon et apam la salle et la
toile et ouvrira dans le monde et les
collages et voit les locaux n'est pas
faisable chez toi tu habites attend
boyard toi d'accord mais dis moi tu
habites dans un bon jour tu habites dans
un nouveau cadre aux bleus non c'est
quoi une une dédicace de claude nougaro
non c'est non mais moi il faut agir et à
moi chez moi y'a d'la merde faut savoir
que rené ta passionnés du moyen âge un
jour j
je passe donc au pinceau et du soul est
ce le 2 mai 10 20 voire amère et me dit
oui mais tu t'habilles en face au
moyen-âge contraire de l est qu elle
dure d'armure x et pas à vous je vous ai
dit en face moyenâgeux alors battu cette
fois ci s'appelle défilé médiéval avait
ma ma cote de maille que j'ai fait moi
lep pratique kg demi siècle car à la
ferme perdue elle le pratique kg de jean
mallet le défilé médiéval à mal lors
d'un mariage tu es bon merci merci merci
sony en fait tout mais en fait vous avez
un peu sonné la merci pour les diplômes
aux noix respecter pour survivre en
couple accélérer le rythme et le cadre
de travail de l'autre 4 raviver la
flamme de l'amour en continuant de
séduire ça veut dire qu'il faut
continuer de séduire
rené est ce que tu te fais des petits
plaisirs avec ta femme c'est à dire tu
dis ce soir on dîne tient tous les deux
ans je vais mettre une petite bouche
on va se faire une petite soirée tous
les deux ou pas du tout oui je lui dis
le sort mal à la tête ou à l'émail et à
bougie pas la bouillie de poisson c'est
super important ce que vous venez de
dire parce qu'il ya un écueil
un dramatique pendant son film en
séquences nombre des départs on a
commencé tout ça un petit peu à ce
laisser aller à ne plus vraiment
s'habiller par exemple à rester en lady
noire djodjic à ne pas s'arrêter a juste
touché et basta or cette nouvelle
vraiment par la texane l'idée c'est que
quand même malgré tout de temps en temps
on essaie d'être un peu apprêtée pour
l'autre de guemps med avec kiel temps
jogging en pyjama très fortement parce
que ça peut détruire le couple
alors je vous donnerai dix commandements
becqueter pour survivre en couple alors
on est donc ravivé la flamme de l'amour
en continuant de séduire se répartir les
tâches mais les tâches ménagères ça il
faut le faire optez pour le yoga ou la
méditation tu réparti les tâches
ménagères toi rené tu fais des tâches
ménagères
oui parce que je vais te dire je suis
dans le village de l'allée pouvait
rester nolwenn est bien chez moi qui
vais vider la poubelle quand même en
voiture craindre les 12 km fait d'armé
alors tu fais quand même des trucs ah
ouais quand même moi c'est quand même
quelque chose zaoui ah oui quand même
ah oui quand même tombé là là là tu m'as
tu l'as tu mates ou mpeg 4 mondial après
traité interprété avec le dos de la
cuillère sur ton amoureux totalement eu
du mal à s'en remettre
il fait des tâches ménagères patache
valérie aubin il fait ici
ouais qui est presque tout mais non
franchement il est génial non mais je
vous dis que vous avez la pression
peut-être que je le jean joly de la
réalité mais il sait tout faire il
bricole et jardine et cuisine du ménage
c'est quoi elle avait te dire la vérité
valérie avec tout ce qu'il sait faire
tous les jours je me demande je vous dit
comment il fait pour avoir plusieurs
morts avec tout ce qu'il fait dans la
journée et trouve le toit
d'autres me suis quand même en privé il
est incroyable ce battage en dixième
position aussi c'est opter pour le yoga
ou la méditation
il fait du yoga ou la méditation dans
pas ici fait soit le sept s'organiser
des rituels à deux mains des petits
trucs on regarde des petites séries
on se dit tiens viens on va secouer bien
on va s'arracher les poils du nez voilà
c'est sympa quoi ça mais lombez en soit
voilà donc n'hésitez pas à le faire
prendre un peu l'air
donc voila comme fair rené rené tous les
soirs il va 500 m sortir la poubelle
voilà les dix commandements à respecter
pour survivre en coupe la rue n'est pas
d'accord faire du sport régulièrement
faire du sport régulièrement ça je sais
qu'ici personne n'en fait mais c'est
sympa d'être là quand même et parler de
ses projets de vie c'est-à-dire il
faudra essayer de se projeter sur ton ce
moment c'est à dire voilà ce qu'on va
faire essayer de faire des projets
ensemble
je sais que valérie à des projets avec
patoche bien entendu ils ont le projet
voilà je le sais je sais ma vérité mais
quoi je connais je connais le project
patoche mais demain on m'a hommage et
entendu parler d'un mariage avec mort
d'homme ou pas du tout si si c'est vrai
alors c'est non mais non mais non mais
pas un mariage de vous deux
un mariage vous êtes invités bientôt
will be quiet way en partie du sport et
on connaît tous votre passion pour le
paddle est ce que depuis deux mois vous
avez pas rompu le confinement par les
jours adolphe vous avez respecté ça où
est-ce que vous avez joué à des jeux
nous regarde pas mais je vais pas jouer
du tout mais ça fait voilà ces gens
s'énervent c'est pour ça qu'on les aime
également
bravo michel